okay let's take a few more calls at 6 1
7 8 3 0 47 50 starting with our caller
from the 705 area code who's calling
today from 705 I think that's me yes
yeah I'm calling from Northern Ontario
Canada great I was wondering if you
could comment on with the pandemic I've
noticed that a lot of especially more
corrupt governments are taking this time
to seize more power than they should for
example in Poland and especially in
Hungary
yep Viktor Orban was given the power to
rule by decree and I was wondering if
you could comment on the state of
democracy in the u.s. because I've seen
some worrying things but both by mail
and gerrymandering that seem that the
Republicans and seem to be trying to do
absolutely so I here in the United
States we have several layers of
[Music]
totalitarian ish tendencies from the
current federal government so one of the
first red flags was when coronavirus
started the Justice Department was
asking for essentially the suspension of
habeas corpus in effect where the
Justice Department wanted a situation
where if they have people being held
pretrial who normally would have a right
to a speedy trial which means the
charges against you are presented you're
you know given a lawyer a court date
that's relatively expeditious given a
chance to prepare a defense etc the
Trump Justice Department wants that
suspended so that they can just hold
people indefinitely and say listen
you're not you've not been sentenced to
prison but you're not getting bail and
you're just gonna sit in prison and the
charges against you aren't moving
forward because courts are operating at
diminished capacity because of
coronavirus extremely totalitarian very
very concerning
we then saw with the protests here in
the United States Donald Trump's first
instinct when we have protests against
police brutality is to say governor's
aren't being brutal enough I'm gonna
send in the the military in order to be
more brutal and to further repress
protest very very totalitarian Donald
Trump using so far using Corona
although I wouldn't be surprised to see
him try to use the protests as well to
justify we shouldn't vote by mail voting
by mail leads to fraud we shouldn't do
it it's just a voter suppression tactic
Trump insists Democrats can only win if
they cheat well it's clear he thinks he
needs to cheat in order to win or at
least suppress the vote so it's very
very disturbing what we're seeing here
before all of this started the united
states and the democracy index was
ranked a flawed democracy and the state
of democracy here is dramatically
declining earlier this week in Georgia
we had huge voter suppression and
strategically left-leaning and non-white
areas I mean it's it's ugly it's very
very ugly yeah that's I think that is
really concerning um one thing I was
going to ask is do you think that with I
don't really understand it because you
know I don't I don't live down there but
I from what I understand it's with
vote-by-mail and stuff like that that's
in the care of the the state secretary
is it the Attorney General or secretary
state there's someone down there an
elected official who controls that is I
think semi independent of the state
legislatures yeah the secretary well
it's it's it's independent of the
legislature but these are elected
positions I believe in just about every
state the Secretary of State and we've
had crazy situations where like in 2018
Brian Kemp was secretary of state in
Georgia and he was candidate for
governor and lo and behold his
overseeing of his own race for governor
led to him becoming governor in Georgia
among widespread allegations of voter
suppression listen I'm gonna have to let
you go because your connection is a bit
problematic and it's coming in a little
bit crunchy but very very important
issues and I'm glad you're paying
attention to them